la cohue et le chaos appréhendé par
beaucoup de français au premier jour du
camp
mon pass vu la période de pointe matin à
vue puces de passagers franchir les
guérit transports publics à paris dans
certaines stations la différence avec la
période de confinement se remarque est à
peine sur plusieurs des lignes de métro
et pas de véhicule malheureusement les
rouges sur obligé de prendre les
transports et je vais étudier
petit à petit la situation en étant à
éviter beaucoup de monde et rhinites et
là elle a fait le choix de la voiture
le transport public ne rassure pas la
jeune femme qui avait à peine mis le nez
dehors ces huit dernières semaines
heureuse de ne plus être au chômage son
retour au travail était malgré tout en
train d'appréhension ce matin on ne sait
pas comment vont réagir les gens et ce
qu'ils vont être nombreux ou pas dans un
premier temps est-ce qu'ils vont venir
masquer ou pas qu'ils vont faire
attention à nous
chez ce coiffeur ces masques pour tout
le monde et distance imposée entre
chaque client pour respecter les
consignes du gouvernement
pour christophe c'était devenu assez
urgent pour qu ils s'éclipsent un moment
du boulot qu'il venait à peine de
retrouver après de longs mois de
télétravail c'est bien de pouvoir
retrouver une une
une image un petit peu qui correspond à
la sienne donc il faut faire travailler
les commerçants aussi qu'ils avaient
besoin de redon
le plus grand cafouillage de cette
première journée de déconfinement c'est
qu'elle est venue sans que la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence sanitaire était
prorogée à temps adopté samedi le
conseil constitutionnel ne l'enterré
n'est qu'en après midi
si bien qu elle ne sera en vigueur que
mercredi modèle le confinement était
très efficace mais avec ou sans loi il
est essentiel que les gestes barrières
soient respectées dit ce chercheur qui a
co rédigé une modélisation de la
propagation du corona virus avec le
déconfinement si une majorité de la
population ne rêve ne respectent pas ces
mesures ou ne le respecte pas sur une
durée de temps suffisamment longue et
bien effectivement tous les bénéfices de
ces mesures pourraient être
considérablement réduite et nous
exposerait je dire exposerait
collectivement au risque de rebond
d'épidémie de déconfinement progressif
et donc un premier test pour voir si la
france est prête à vivre avec le virus
qui circule toujours la clé donc de
contrôler sa propagation
si elle devait de nouveau augmenter les
autorités ont prévenu
il faudrait revenir en arrière et
confiner les français de nouveau ce qui
après ce premier goût de liberté frais
sans doute très mal ici marie-eve bédard
radio canada